u.s president joe biden says the new
omicron variant is a cause for concern
but not for panic several countries
along with the u.s have clamped down on
international travel now they include
japan which has banned all foreign
arrivals morocco has halted all inbound
flights and israel has closed its
borders for two weeks
the u.s brazil australia and indonesia
are among countries to bar travelers
from southern african nations where the
variant was first reported
now along with cutting air links to
southern african countries the travel
bans have had the knock-on effect of
leaving thousands of travelers stranded
they want is to go home but since the
new coronavirus variant omicron was
first detected in southern africa travel
restrictions around the world have
tightened flights got cancelled and
these travelers in south africa are
still looking for a way out
i flew in on tuesday to joburg
from the uk
obviously the bands came in thursday
friday and so i got stuck
i think there's several thousand
europeans trying to get home via the
only routes available which i think now
are kenya and ethiopia
it is frustrating because
it was a short holiday and
and it turned out to be a nightmare
u.s president joe biden says they are
not planning additional travel
restrictions and defend the ban on
visitors from southern african nations
it gives us time gives us time to take
more actions
to move quicker to make sure people
understand you have to get your vaccine
you have to get the shot you have to get
to get the booster if you're
this variant is a cause for concern
not a cause for panic
with people around the world tired of
pandemic restrictions and another round
of lockdowns and travel bans the world
health organization is urging the global
community to be cautious
we shouldn't need another wake-up call
we should all be wide awake to the
threat of this virus
but omicron's very emergence is another
reminder that although many of us might
think we're done with covet 19.
it's not done with us
with little information yet about how
dangerous omicron is some nations have
walled themselves off entirely like
morocco it has suspended all incoming
air travel for two weeks
and we can get more on this with
journalist and molecular biologist kai
kup fashion who joins us from here in
berlin thanks so much for your time now
the who has assessed the overall risk
from the omicron variant as very high
what do they mean by that exactly
well this is still based on the same
information that we've talked about in
the last few days um it's not different
from what the european centers for
disease control said a few days ago as
well it just means
the the genome of this virus really
looks like it could have the ability to
evade immunity to some extent it could
transmit very well and of course that
would be a problem and the first
indications we have from the little data
we have in south africa suggest that
that might be happening that it could
replace delta but again we don't know
that yet um and so they're just being
cautious i mean that's why they call it
a variant of concern and that's why
they're saying there's a high risk
okay now the ceo of the vaccine
manufacturer moderna has said that
covid19 vaccines are unlikely to be
as effective against the omicron variant
as they have been previously so what
does this uh change how does this change
the global vaccination effort
well again that is something we're going
to have to see i mean clearly everybody
who looks at that genome who has any
understanding of antibodies and the the
sites that antibodies bind to is really
concerned because
these are the sites that are mutated in
this virus and but we're going to have
to wait and see how big the drop is and
that's going to decide about how how
much of an impact this has really
globally and
certainly it could be possible that we
need to update the vaccines that's
something that people have talked about
for a long time already luckily it
hasn't been necessary so far
and then of course we're going to run
into all the same problems that we've
run into before which means we're going
to have to produce
massive amounts of a vaccine in a short
time period and from what i've seen so
far we're not going to be able to
distribute it equitably across the globe
unless we really redouble our efforts on
that front as well
now omicron is the latest in a string of
coronavirus mutations people are tired
of the ongoing restrictions how many
more um mutations are we likely to see
is there any any light at the end of the
corona tunnel right now
i mean
that that's of course someone nobody can
can tell right at the moment um what we
have seen this virus has been surprising
in just how well it has been able to
adapt not just to humans also to a host
of animal species and i think that's
something that maybe a lot of scientists
also underestimated in the beginning but
certainly everybody has always said you
know it takes two things for evolution
and one of them is that these mutations
have to come up in the first place which
is essentially chance so the more
infections you have the more likely you
are to get any any evolution at all and
then the second part is an evolutionary
pressure now as this virus sweeps
through humanity and immunity builds up
and we vaccinate people which also
builds up immunity of course the
evolutionary pressure is there so all we
can do at the moment really is to reduce
the number of infections globally and
cut off these these ways for the virus
to to evolve around our defenses but
we've been doing a very bad job of that
i'm afraid and as long as that continues
the chances are that the virus is also
going to continue to evolve and find new
ways to make trouble
all right kai schmidt many thanks for
for your time
earlier we spoke to the world health
organization spokesperson christian
lintmeier in geneva switzerland and we
asked him if the omicron variant is more
dangerous in countries with low
vaccination rates such as south africa
that's difficult to say yet because we
don't yet know the severity of this
virus of the of this variant
so omicron is not yet fully known it
looks like
it's more transmissible that's what the
preliminary evidence shows that it might
also break few immunity possibly easier
um but we again we do not yet know much
about the the variant and we do not know
whether it's more or even possibly less
severe um so we have to wait for that to
see but yes
the more a virus spreads in a community
or a society which is less vaccinated
the higher the risk that we have more
severe cases there that we have more
people in emergency wards and therefore
blocking up the health care system and
therefore also enabling in a chain
reaction other diseases to come up let's
not forget this is not an isolated show
and um
if one society is hit by that then again
if we come back to square one then the
virus will mutate and change and will
come back to us all so yes we need
vaccines
out there to as many people as possible
but for on your personal level if you
are offered a third shot because of your
immune immunodeficiency your immune
system is uh maybe requiring it and you
want to get your immune reaction up then
yes you should take it but on the
national level let's try to share as
much as vaccines as possible with those
who need it
turning to germany now where chancellor
angela merkel and her likely successor
olaf schultz will be holding crisis
talks today on tackling the pandemic
although the country's seven-day
incidence rate has fallen slightly some
hospital awards are full and the
incoming government is under pressure to
make vaccinations mandatory
no customers at this vaccination center
in the german state of saxony the region
has the highest coronavirus caseload in
the country vaccinating the population a
high priority yet they don't have the
doctors to administer the vaccine
it's really only a matter of personnel
we do have enough vaccine but we have
only two mobile vaccine teams for the
entire district
hospitals here are at capacity icu
patients need to be transferred across
germany to guarantee care a crisis that
can only be managed through additional
vaccinations say scientists
industry our data shows that both
vaccinations and booster shots do really
make a difference
if we vaccinate quickly we could break
this wave in december
germany's incoming government says all
options are on the table including
vaccine mandates
the question is whether we need to move
the school christmas break forward and
we need to discuss and prepare a
vaccination mandate
hard choices for outgoing chancellor
angela merkel when she sits down with
regional leaders later today
all right let's bring in dw's chief
political editor mikhail koffner who can
tell us more about all of this michelada
chancellor angela merkel and her
successor will love
as we just heard we'll be meeting with
the leaders of germany's 16 federal
states today can you tell us
more about what they'll be discussing
well they're clearly discussing of what
the next measures will have to be in the
face of the fourth wave of the pandemic
it's safe to say that both the now
departing government of angela merkel
but also the incoming government have
been caught off guard by this full force
of the fourth wave only today after more
than three weeks we're seeing a
stabilization
in terms of infection rates which are
still above 400 so things that had been
initially ruled out like mandatory
vaccinations which parties across the
board had pretty much ruled out and now
being discussed for real and also a
potential contact restrictions nobody
wants to use the l word the lock down
word because that is something
that um parties have been increasingly
shying away from because there were also
constitutional alarm bells ringing
particularly amongst
delegates or mps from the free democrat
liberal party who launched proceedings
before the constitutional court on this
that's right now the german federal
constitutional court is actually set to
rule today whether a nighttime curfew
and strict uh limits on social contacts
that were implemented last spring were
in fact unconstitutional how could that
impact the the current fight against the
fourth wave
what will make all the difference
because the constitutional court which
initially initially was thought to way
too late uh to really make a difference
is now um coming right in the midst of
this fourth wave and it will rule on a
whole host of measures also including
school closures but the whole question
of lockdown the emergency brake measures
that are now no longer possible
because the incoming coalition
had
those suspended introduced a new set of
measures a more limited catalogue of
measures now we're talking about fast
massive expansion of those again and
here politicians actively waited until
after this constitutional court ruling
to make sure whatever they launch from
now
will not be contested within the court
within days
now germany um says it wants to
administer 20 million booster shots
before the end of the year is it on
track to do that
yes and no we heard biontech
now pledge to three more
millions of doses that could be
delivered here in germany but as we saw
in the report it's very sketchy in some
places there's no personnel in other
places they're not there's not enough
vaccine and that's also
why a new
new
drive is now being launched within the
incoming chancery which is to be headed
by someone from the military at least
projecting kind of military style
logistics and operation
whether that will translate on the
ground when for instance dentists and
will be asked to join this drive and
that's a big question mark for now
all right dw's chief political editor
mikhail koffner thanks so much
and here are some of the other
developments in the pandemic around the
world
chinese president xi jinping says his
country will send an additional 1
billion doses of covert 19 vaccines to
nations in africa britain will offer a
booster shot to all adults in a bid to
accelerate its vaccination program face
masks will be compulsory in shops and on
public transport in england from today
and the philippines have launched a
three-day drive to vaccinate up to nine
million filipinos tens of thousands of
military and police officers plus
thousands of volunteers have been
deployed nationwide
you